you know what they say the couple that
wears matching jerseys together stays
together life is pretty good check out
zendaya and tom holland sitting in the
stands at the new york rangers game on
thursday
both supporting the team and their
relationship zendaya sports a rangers
jersey with holland across the back
while toms reads what else zendaya it's
just the beginning of this really
adorable romance that we're watching
kind of bloom on camera full witness to
the adorable pair's matching outfits is
zendaya's euphoria co-star hunter
schaefer and tom's younger brother harry
holland and during the night z and t
leaned in close to chat probably about
the game but were hoping they were
planning their next coordinated look i
just feel very lucky but this isn't the
couple's first outing in the big apple
this week
on wednesday they did some retail
therapy at a prada store then later that
night the two held hands while leaving a
hotel together rocking a similar vibe
both wearing black zenaya is the one at
serving looks she is the one to go for
for tips
yeah come on this is zendaya we're
talking about the emmy winner turns
heads everywhere she goes
remember when she wore this stunning
creation at the spider-man no way home
premiere it stopped tom completely in
his tracks
so how are you feeling about that and
tackling that they're losing things i
think zendaya just sounds like they're
just showed up
following that mesmerizing moment the
two took their love abroad visiting the
uncharted star's parents in london and
this quality time zendaya and tom are
spending together is well deserved
following the december release of their
marvel film which fun fact is now the
third highest grossing movie of all time
i honestly feel a little bit numb
like this has been the most incredible
experience this whole journey from the
day i got cast and my agents are here we
were just talking about the moment i got
my first call back and we really thought
like oh wow maybe i could actually get
this job and here we are today some
suggest that parker's powers include the
male spider's ability to hypnotize
females stop come on yes my spider lord
big question now is will we ever see the
couple together on screen again i don't
know how excited people would be to just
jump on board when e.t chatted with the
actress about season two of euphoria she
teased the idea of tom making a cameo
listen we talked about it you know
because uh
um he supported me through the whole the
whole season and you know we we joke
about like just fitting him into the
background
it was an easter egg see if someone can
can spot him
[Music]